from ambitious mind-bending sci-fi
movies to murder mysteries and war epics
Christopher Nolan has put a unique stamp
on Hollywood during his two decade
career as a director and proved that
ambitious original ideas can make just
as much box-office Bank as comic-book
superheroes if you're good at something
never do it for free with a level of
critical and commercial success than
most filmmakers never come close to
Nolan's only real competition in the
industry is himself but how do his movie
stack up against each other here's our
ranking starting with number 10
following even Christopher Nolan's worst
movie is pretty darn good but more than
anything it stands out as a testament to
his early promise as a filmmaker
clocking in at just over an hour this
super short movie revolves around a man
whose hobby is following strangers which
it turns out is pretty weird when you're
doing it in real life and not on Twitter
when it's demanding that's when it
started to go along with a narrative
that jumps around between the future and
present it's no surprise that critics
see following as a harbinger of the
great work Nolan would produce in years
to come
insomnia Nolan's breakout as a filmmaker
came with memento in 2000 but it's the
movie he made after that one that's next
in our reverse ranking this suspenseful
crime thriller is a remake of the 1997
Norwegian film of the same name and
nolan used his alaskan setting to
spectacular effect and in addition to
the kind of intricate plot that would
become a trademark of his work the
director also proved that he could
wrangle a talented cast of a-listers
insomnia is led by Al Pacino and Robin
Williams who delivered one of his most
chilling performances The Prestige smart
mysterious and featuring a totally
underrated cameo by David Bowie this
period piece pulls off one of the best
twists in modern cinema the story
follows a pair of dueling illusionists
played by Hugh Jackman and Christian
Bale as they battle to rule the magic
scene in late 1800s London
hey where do you go we won't spoil the
big reveal but let's just say that this
movie has a lot of its sleeve making it
a memorable and ambitious entry into
Nolan's catalog The Dark Knight Rises
the final entry in Nolan's Dark Knight
trilogy is a fantastic film it's just
not as good as the first two which is
why it's here on the bottom half of the
list
Nolan brought his series to arousing end
by turning the entire city of Gotham
into a war zone with imposing bad-guy
Bane as the villain in chief along with
Anne Hathaway a Selina Kyle The Dark
Knight Rises brought a brand of spark
and wit the franchise had been missing
and even if the formula was arguably
stretched a bit thin by now
the director still managed to send his
Batman out with a bang interstellar
Nolan walked a tightrope with this
sci-fi flick combining a space adventure
with a metaphysical message about the
transcendent power of love ambitious but
Nolan worked hard to get the science
right and create a stunning blockbuster
spectacle while also never losing touch
with his story's heart at the middle of
it all is a mission to save humanity and
a poignant performance by Matthew
McConaughey as a hero on the verge of a
life-changing sacrifice memento we're
into the top five with the movie the
first put Nolan on the map and a
textbook example of what makes him such
a great filmmaker starring Guy Pearce as
the world's most unreliable narrator it
forces the audience to piece together
its story one tiny detail at a time
backwards using only a bunch of
Polaroids and tattooed clues on the skin
of its protagonist who hasn't the
foggiest idea how his own story began
look I'm sorry I don't remember you
it's nothing personal fortunately nobody
has amnesia when it comes to recognizing
memento as Nolan's first cinematic
masterpiece as both writer and director
he showed Hollywood he had the chops to
take big original high concept ideas and
turned them into something critics and
audiences alike would rave about Batman
Begins it's here
the Batman
the superhero franchise was in shambles
when Christopher Nolan's pitch for a
back-to-basics approach put it back on
track and reinvented the genre in the
bargain Batman Begins nailed the classic
characters origin story and introduced a
whole new generation of fans to the Dark
Knight and it put Batman back on top of
the box office for the first time in
ages
proving that its director had the chops
to help blockbusters that were so much
more than simple pop cornflakes
inception let's be honest for most
directors setting an action-packed heist
film inside multiple sub layers of an
increasingly complex turning world would
have resulted in a mess of epic
proportions but for Christopher Nolan
that premise made for a mind-bending
masterpiece with an all-star cast led by
Leonardo DiCaprio Joseph gordon-levitt
Tom Hardy and Ellen Page inception may
still be the directors most remarkable
project a dizzyingly complex story and
jaw-dropping visual effects extravaganza
and one what might be most impressive
though is that Nolan is one of few
directors who Hollywood would dream of
trusting with a non franchise picture
this ambitious Dunkirk despite the
uncountable number of world war ii
movies that have come out of Hollywood
Christopher Nolan's still managed to
give the military conflict a fresh spin
with this story about the daring
real-life evacuation of Allied troops
from the French city of Dunkirk instead
of a big sweeping battlefield epic Nolan
got right up close to the action with
multiple perspectives across three
different timelines featuring a talented
ensemble cast that included a few
familiar faces from Gotham City critics
were seriously impressed in this
inspirational film as the directors best
yet with one exception the Dark Knight
if Nolan's Batman trilogy is the best
superhero franchise ever made this movie
is its crown jewel
hi the late Heath Ledger stole every
scene with a mesmerizing oscar-winning
performance as the Joker and Christian
Bale was in full command of the Caped
Crusader's cowl not to mention his
memorable bat voice critics and
audiences alike loved The Dark Knight
and many people were furious when it was
snubbed in the Best Picture category and
for good reason it's not just one of the
best superhero movies of the past decade
it's one of the best movies ever period
and that's why it's number 1 on our list
of Nolan's greatest hits no clowning
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]